[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KERPELMAN: Hello, I'm Todd
Kerpelman for The Developer
Show.
Hey, you know what's cool?
Developer news.
And this here is your weekly
update on the coolest developer
news from Google.
Last summer we released the
first official 1.0 version
of Spring Cloud GCP, providing
idiomatic spring support
for Cloud Pub/Sub, Cloud SQL,
Stackdriver Trace, Stackdriver
Logging, and Cloud Storage.
And last week, we released
another major release
with new integration, bug fixes,
and yes, documentation updates,
including Spring Data support
for Cloud Spanner and Cloud
Datastore.
Examples and a link to get
started are on the post.
In collaboration with
Sony Pictures Imageworks,
we recently announced
OpenCue, an open source,
high performance Render
Manager specifically built
for the needs of the visual
effects and animation industry.
The full story and a
link to the GitHub repo
are both on the post.
The Cloud Search Connector SDK
gives Cloud Search partners
an easier way to index
third-party content
and identities.
And last week, we open sourced
the Google Cloud Search
Connector SDK and all reference
connectors built by Google.
To learn how it works and get
a link to the GitHub repo,
head on over to the post.
Chrome 73-- whoo, 73--
is available with
updates to Dev tools,
including log points, style
properties, and Inspect Mode,
the ability to export
code coverage data
as a JSON file and much more.
All the updates are--
yep, you guessed it--
on the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Todd Kerpelman for
The Developer Show.
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
Chi chi chi chi hey
chi chi chi chi chi.
SPEAKER 1: Is that a
Fortnite dance originally?
SPEAKER 2: No.
No.
It's the Backpack Kid.
TODD KERPELMAN: No.
SPEAKER 2: [INAUDIBLE]